If you are thinking about having children these days or becoming future parents,
Many know that fertility decreases with age.
So, when should you have children?
Is there anything you can do to overcome your biological clock?
The menstrual period usually begins in women at the age of 12 or 13 years
But most ovaries do not begin to release eggs until several years of this age.
In fact, women's fertility is only peak when they reach the beginning or mid-twenties.
Unlike males, they produce sperm continuously
Women have a limited number of eggs, but do not worry.
Once you reach puberty, you have about 30,000 eggs
Much more than the 300 to 400 eggs that are released during a lifetime,
However, widespread statistics show that after one-year gestation attempts,
A 30-year-old woman has a 25%
The rate of failure increases to 44% for a 35-year-old woman,
And up to 66% for a 40-year-old woman.
But most of these data were published in an academic journal published in 2004, concerned with birth records in France
Between 1670 and 1830
We can say that there have been many changes in the lives and health of women
Since the era of electricity, antibiotics and reliable food.
It is not related to the number of times sex is practiced and the fact that it gradually decreases with age
Recent studies offer a more optimistic look
For the percentage of women who are unable to conceive during a year of unsecured intimate relationships
By 13% to 14% for women between the twenty-seventh and thirty-fourth
And 18% of women between 35 and 39
The study continues to show fertility decline
But it offers better opportunities than old research has suggested
Another study showed that women between 38 and 39 years old
Who had previously been pregnant
They have an 80% chance of being naturally pregnant within six months
This indicates another error in studies
Almost half of the pregnancies in America are unintentional
This means that most fertile women become inadvertently pregnant
While those who deliberately attempt to have children for the first time after the age of 30 are less fertile regardless of age
This reinforces the vital role of aging
However, older eggs may not be fertilized normally
Which increases the proportion of chromosomal changes with age
Women at the age of 30 receive 1/800 for a child with Down syndrome
But the probability increases by the age of forty to reach 1/100 but it remains a chance of 1%
But what about men? Many think that man's fertility is limitless thanks to famous examples such as Charlie Chaplin
Who gave birth until his 70s
While males continue to produce sperm.
The greater the cell division, the greater the probability of mutations
When the male reaches the age of 50, the sperm cells have undergone 800 cycles of division and multiplication
As a result, adult parents are increasingly at risk for children
Schizophrenia in personality, autism, cancer, type of dwarfism and fibromyalgia
And even skull and facial abnormalities, even among younger parents in the Western world
Sperm counts have decreased by 50% in the past 40 years
The implications and importance of this have not yet been determined
Yet there is still much to learn about raising children rather than living
Statistical points indicate that young parents have more energy
But older parents have physical maturity and stability
Of course high income does not mean good parents
But studies have shown that high family income means a high SAT rate
Not to mention that in middle and low income countries
The chance of death among girls between the ages of 15 and 19 during childbirth is 28% higher for women aged 20 and 24 years
Studies have also been found in some sub-Saharan African countries
That 25% of girls and adolescents are absent from school because of unintended pregnancy
Preserving the eggs of younger women with physical refrigeration is common
But it is not guaranteed with age
Still affects the success rates of pregnancy and researchers believe that the cooling process reduces the efficiency of oocytes
Moreover, this is not an option for most women because the cost of cooling alone is estimated at $ 10,000
And a laboratory inoculation cycle, which could cost up to $ 12,000
in general . Yes, having children becomes more difficult as men and women grow older
But he did not reach the stage of concern imagined by the media
Fertility is a variable thing that depends on genes and lifestyles
The best time to have children is a very personal decision
As in the lack of desire to have children
Special thanks to the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation for their support of this episode
Although the world is on a huge road of progress
It is important to remember that progress is not inevitable
This is why the Gates Foundation has created a "Goal Report" that will help raise awareness, sense responsibility and work hard for a better future
Did you know that the number of mothers who died during childbirth has halved in the last generation?
The Gates Foundation wants to ensure a healthy and continuous life and promote health for people of all ages
Click the link in the description to read the report and see the progress made by the institution
And continued the channel for more scientific sections weekly every Thursday
Translation: team translate @autrjim